[Music]
a global pandemic
a climate change emergency a social
awakening
2020 has been a year like no other
the uk has left the european union
we filmed as trees exploded into flames
this was a functioning hospital before
the airstrike started happening
you must stay at home
[Music]
how is it health biblically
harry and megan step back as senior
royals next
president of the united states joe biden
i believe that to pursue
that things will get better
each week sky news speaks to hundreds of
people from all walks of life from prime
ministers to celebrities
and ordinary people with extraordinary
tales to tell here are some of their
stories
we should not go in and trash
an area of the globe about which we know
hardly anything
it's a hell of that it's been nice
he's tried to uh hijack uh
christianity and the bible but sitting
ahead to my father he understands me is
not the first to move
i thought about my kids and i said no i
cannot die today for my kids i cannot
i've got to see them
isn't the same is it you want to you
really want to give people a hug
been so many misconceptions about me so
i wanted to show people who i really was
you need to look deep into your heart
and your soul and figure out everyone
that's watching
what you're going to do to contribute
[Music]
this is the majestic nile the world's
longest river
crucial to the survival of millions of
people
but now the river's existence is
threatened like never before
niall is a man with a mission to do
everything in his power to try to save
the river
nile is like life for the people of this
country
and it has been for a very long time and
we this
generation we should also make sure we
preserve the nile for the coming
generation
as as it was maintained for us
he is in no doubt what constitutes one
of the greatest threats facing the
region during the rainy season
all this place will all be covered by
the water bottle
and the plastic bags how big would you
say the problem is
is this is enormous these things are
piling up and these are the most
areas that are so beneficial to the
people of south sudan
all the fish the fisheries are based in
those areas
that's where we get a lot of fish and
areas that are being used
for our kettles these are the areas that
are mostly affected
you see the the plastic bag effect
on the environment and i feel that the
nile is shocking
the richest of the nile is gone
[Music]
when i say the nile is shocking the nile
is dying after all
if we don't see it dying today the night
is going to die soon after us
if nothing is done now nile's
unpopularity
makes his job a dangerous one many of
the store keepers here are deeply
unhappy with his campaign
and he has to be accompanied by his
bodyguards at all times
nile runs into one of the young couriers
who supply the stall holders
what do you have there
[Music]
okay you are under arrest
you're under arrest you're the one i'm
looking for
thank you i'm determined to make sure
this
this this plastic is gone out of this
country
[Music]
wards of patients many not elderly
fighting to breathe
and as our team there discovered the
impact of the suffering reaches
far outside the hospital walls they're
fighting a war here
and they are losing
[Music]
it is apocalyptic and of course here
they're calling it
the apocalypse
the man tasked with dealing with this
crisis while protecting his family and
leading his community
is the mayor giorgio gory he imposed the
lockdown
he's doing this to save his town but
he's unwittingly designing policies that
all of europe are about to follow
how are you he doesn't know it but he's
changing history
is your message to the outside world if
you like that you have to love that
absolutely
yes absolutely yes i i have two
uh daughters they they are studying
in england uh one in taunton in college
and the other
and the other in canterbury she's doing
a master
and when i saw what the
english government was thinking about
this this problem i decided to
to bring them back because i think that
even if we are at the center of the
message epidemio epidemic the the
epidemic
probably they are probably more
secure sure here than
than in england because i don't
understand why the government
didn't decide for time in time
to protect the the citizens
he's scared the world isn't listening
nobody takes any risks they wash and
sanitize constantly
gloves masks and protective clothes are
regularly changed
in truth these men and women are
exhausted
the system is at breaking point and they
are as well
but they keep going they aren't the
front line in this war
they are the only one
it's a very dangerous is
a disaster is a a tsunami
and we are here
12 hours a day
only we are go to home
for a a few hours
and come back here for
the work because we are
[Music]
here for the patients
university hospital coventry now at 98
capacity and facing a perfect winter
storm
tom has been on this unit for three
weeks
he spent his 51st birthday here alone
i was absolutely terrified you know i'm
in here
away from my family tom's wife is a
nurse
she realized his cough was more than a
normal cold
her action might have saved tom's life
it's a hell of that it's not been nice
it's a hard road and it's it's a slow
recovery
it's so evil this thing it doesn't carry
you off
it it takes you down and it really you
struggle to beat it
like i say i've witnessed people go you
know
they're not made here you know that's a
real shocker
you've seen people die i literally see
i've seen two people die
in this ward well i've been on it so
yeah
that's that's that's just a harsh you
know
it's really hard but it's a really
gives you a reality shot of just how
serious this is
the prince of wales has often been
criticized as being out of touch
but in a rare show of affection for his
family he's described how like many
others during lockdown
he's craving human contact prince
charles described
how he's missing his father who'll be 99
next week
and his grandchildren and wants to give
them a hug early on the prince of wales
like the rest of us seem to be
struggling with cutting contact because
of covert
but speaking from scotland where he
spent lockdown he admitted that being
away from his family
has been the hardest part of this
pandemic
people are just desperate to see their
families really are they it's it's a
it's a challenging time
well i mean i haven't seen my father for
a long time and he's he's going to be 99
next week
and uh so yes all my grandchildren are
anything so
i've been doing well the facetime is all
real well
how has that been for you being being
disconnected from your family if you
don't mind me asking well i mean
it's terribly sad let alone one's
friends
but um i mean fortunately you know at
least you can
speak to them on television and
occasionally do this sort of thing but
it isn't the same is it you want to
you really want to give people a hug
yes i'd suspect you're not the only one
who who would love to to be able to to
embrace
their relatives um and hopefully that
time
is coming very soon well i i do hope so
because
well i don't worry i totally understand
so many people's frustration
difficulties grief and anguish
i know that so many people have had the
agony of losing
you know their loved ones and the
bewilderment and
anxiety that surrounds everything and so
[Music]
it is the most awful aspect of a
pandemic
like this and and yet we've seen at the
same time
people being quite remarkable and
wonderful people in the national health
service and all the other key
workers who've kept everything going and
that is
the remarkable thing about this it
always produces the best in everybody in
so many ways
this globally has affected everybody um
and it's affected everybody in very
personal ways for example
um you had the virus yourself how much
did that motivate you to
look at what can be done next and where
we go forward
yes it makes me even more determined to
push and shove and shout and
prod if you see what i mean and whatever
i can do
behind the scenes sometimes but but yes
i mean i i
i suppose it did partly i mean i was
lucky
in my case and um
and and got away with it quite lightly
but
in order to prevent this happening to so
many more people this is why
i'm so determined to find
a way how out of this in order to
bring the world and all of us back to
to the center back to understanding
what we have to do in relationship to
the natural world
so david attenborough says governments
must enforce a ban on industrial mining
of the deep sea because he fears big
business could trash the oceans
sir david who is speaking exclusively to
sky news backed a new report by
fauna and flora international that says
the thirst for heavy metals like cobalt
could lead to widespread and destructive
mining
the world has become very anxious to get
hold of
rare metals which until now have been
found in
places in africa particularly which we
use
in many of the modern electronic
apparatus particularly
batteries um and so uh
there has been a big search put on and
human beings being the sort of people
they are they they look everywhere
and someone says what about the deep
seas and stuff there
and there's certain indications that
there could be what we are asking
is that we should not go in and trash
an area of the globe about which we know
hardly anything
until we've done the proper research on
this
issue at the moment of of coronavirus
now i know you've
talked in in the past talked actually
quite recently about
overpopulation the amount of people on
the planet and the effect that is in
particular having
on other species could this be another
dimension of that of people living
cheek by jowl and then the ability of
viruses to pass
through quite easily black death
when was that 14th century something
like that yeah no not so many people
around
the black death killed thousands of
people
thousands of people and the size of the
world population or indeed the
population of this country or europe
was tiny compared with what it is now so
epidemics can go around the world and
have gone round the world
in the past uh i would like to say whoa
whoa it's all our fault because that's a
kind of fashionable thing to say
that we're overpopulated now but it just
doesn't
that argument doesn't hold
it was water global hit nearly two
decades ago and now
where is the love by the black-eyed peas
has been reimagined in the run-up
to the u.s presidential election people
light
and they will find the way give
people light those are words for our
time
the seven-time grammy award-winning
musician entrepreneur
and activist williams spoke to sky news
about the adaptation i started thinking
about
all the things that are at stake
and how backwards we have you know
traveled
all the progress that was made all the
freedom fighters that fought for
the civil liberties that we have um
although we're not totally there yet but
it doesn't make any sense to go
backwards
it doesn't make sense that we have a
leader that steers up hate that
amplifies
you know division and tries his hardest
to confuse us all with distractions
it doesn't make sense that we have a
leader that doesn't listen to science
doesn't make sense that we have a leader
that handled covert the way we've
handled to where people have lost so
many
families lives and so many jobs
so many people facing eviction because
they can't pay their bills
and with all that i just asked like
where
why are we here in this place and when i
when i heard joe biden's speech at the
dnc i realized that that sentiment that
he
had in that speech marries where's the
love
so the question for us is simple are we
ready
i believe we are we must be with so many
distractions people forget so soon
and we've been so immune and numb to
just the inhumane things that you know
have been have gone on that we wanted
just to remind people
you got to think about what you're going
to do to contribute i know what i'm
going to do to contribute
i'm going to choose 10 states in america
to start robotics programs
uh that in communities that reflect the
community that i come from in east los
angeles boyle heights
and i want to get kids prepared for this
technological tomorrow so i'm starting
10 robotics programs in
underserved communities to prepare the
youth and that's
that's the least that i can do and i'm
gonna do that right
um so you need to look deep into your
heart and your soul and
figure out everyone that's watching what
you're gonna do to contribute
when biden is elected
[Music]
dominique clayton trayvon martin brianna
taylor
[Applause]
if we're not going to listen we're going
to scream louder and louder and we're
not going to stop until something is
done
no my hate cries please enough we want
the black community to be one that's
what we're fighting for we've got the
same features
like everybody else it's just our skin
color is different
we have an exclusive interview with
george floyd's son quincy
who says he can't stop watching the
video if his father's final minutes
those eight minutes and 46 seconds under
the knee of a white police officer
in minneapolis in may this year in a
special
report as part of our coverage of black
history month
we've brought quincy together with
neville lawrence whose son stephen was
murdered in a racist attack
in london in april 1993.
sky's not phillips has this exclusive
interview i can't stop watching the
video
i watch this video almost over and over
not every day but every now and then i
just think about it
it's a sort of grief neville lawrence
knows all too well
we've brought the two men together for
the first time
when i saw the incident with your dad
being kneeling on on the floor with that
man
kneeling on his neck and the other
officers
around standing and watching tears came
out my eyes
like george floyd stephen lawrence's
racist killing
27 years ago has left an indelible mark
in british society how did you get
through
the tragedy of having what happened to
your son um
we had to go into counseling
the old family had to go into counseling
and and talk about it
even now really right now you know if i
went to
if i went to a funeral to see somebody
being buried
i can't go near when they're putting the
per the
the coffin down i can't go near it
because i'm looking and thinking that
i'm re-burying stephen again
i remember watching your dad's funeral
on tv and seeing just how emotional
and just how raw it was for your family
can you describe what it was like for
you
it's like you see them breathing
my knees just kind of buckle
i kiss him in the forehead let him know
that everything's going to be all right
your son is going to be here with
your families here with you you're not
going to go out and bang
and we were to go bury him
what is it like for you when you hear
those words i can't breathe
the knee on his neck said he couldn't
breathe call out for mama
it's devastating and i have
chills just thinking about what he was
saying
it's not going to be very easy and
and for for all the years that i've been
struggling it hasn't been easy but
you have to have um a ham in view
and the him in view of my family was to
try and get justice
it took us a long time but eventually we
got some justice
and you can't give up you know you gotta
keep fighting
in 2012 two men were finally jailed for
life
for the racist murder of neville's son
i have a hard time trusting any cops
right about now
i'm not saying all kinds of bad cops
are not good
but shouldn't have to my father
demonstrated needing that question
[Music]
her name alone is enough to trigger an
emotional reaction hillary clinton
knows she's a divisive figure even if
she's not
quite sure why
obviously i tried to warn about him
when i was running against him and
yet once it was over i hoped along with
many americans that he would rise to the
job that he would
not be as bad as i feared in the way
that uh he has
uh beh he had behaved in the campaign
sadly
he's been even worse and the covet 19
crisis
really sums up uh the the
deep uh failures of his presidency
during the 2016 campaign from the very
first speech that i gave
until the you know final uh votes were
counted
i was stressing the importance of
dealing
with racial injustice certainly in our
policing system
but in all of our institutions
sadly um given what happened in that
election
and the kind of leadership we've had
since then
it has taken a series of dreadful
uh terrible killings uh to
awaken uh the attention
of the majority in our country about the
need for
real change
[Music]
the protesters that trump tried to
characterize as thugs um were the ones
he
literally ordered our military to clear
from the square in front of the white
house
[Music]
they were totally peaceful protesters
and
what he was trying to do as he often
does is to mischaracterize them
and their uh behavior and their goals
and lump them in with the tiny tiny
minority of people who took advantage
of a tragic moment uh two loops and two
steel and two vandalized a tiny
tiny percentage and he wanted to cast
that over the millions of you know very
thoughtful non-violent peaceful
protesters
for a photo opportunity holding a book
he's never read
stay violent and he can't tell you a
single thing that's in it that
has been a pattern he's tried to uh
hijack christianity and the bible
in ways that are you know deeply
hypocritical
uh and that was just another occasion
and the
outcry by uh religious leaders i think
demonstrated uh clearly that nobody was
being fooled
[Music]
formula one's romana grosjean has said
he thought he would die after the
horrific crash which split his car in
two
this is the moment the world of formula
one held its breath
it was 20 seconds before roman grosjean
emerged from this
fireball just how did he walk away alive
and relatively unscathed
it's 28 seconds but for me it looks more
like one minute thirty and
you will see through the explanation so
it stops open my eyes
under the seat belt sting will gone and
i live
i want to jump out and i hit something
on top of my helmet i feel i hate
something so
i sit back down and so i must be upside
down against the barrier so i will uh
i will wait that they come and help me
so i sit back down and i
look on the right and i look on the left
and then they say oh it's all orange
that's strange
a few things is it sunset no it's not
sunset it's the light from the circuits
no
also the tear off starts to melt so oh
it's fire okay no i don't have time that
um
they come so this time i try to go up a
bit more to the right it doesn't work
go back down try a bit more to the left
it doesn't work so i sit back down and
then
then there's a bit of swearing going on
and i said no i can't
i can't finish like this i can't finish
i thought about nikki lauda because to
me
it was it's funny is that the one that
the driver that i love the most to his
story of formula one
and i said no no i can't finish like
nikki can't finish like this cannot be
my last race
it can't not be my last race so i try
again
i'm stuck and there and then comes the
path which is the less
funny one one is not the word but the
most scary one is
is i sit back down all my muscle relaxes
almost no other smile but in peace with
myself
thinking i'm dead i will die and then i
thought
which parts can i burn first is it the
food is it the hands this is going to be
painful
very very strange feeling you know i
think
you know sometimes we we are close to
death we're a bit scared
this time this for me was was here and
then i named it
don't ask me why i just i just had to
put a name on it and
and i'll call it burnout and then and
then
i don't know if that moment allowed me
to recover a bit get my
brain try to find another solution i
thought about my kids and i said no
i cannot die today for my kids i cannot
i've got to see them
and then i had the idea to to twist my
head like this
go up and turn my body and it works but
then my foot is stuck on the on
on the pedal so i've got to go back down
in the car
pull as hard as i can on my on my left
leg
i mean the shoe stayed where my foot was
and my foot
came out and then i'd do it again and i
went through and the shoulder went
through and at the time i knew the
shoulder
had passed the halo part i was going to
leave you know i
have i know i've got two of my hands on
the fire on the halo i can
i can see my gloves they're red normally
they start
going full black and and i can feel the
pain
and the burn but i'm going up
then i jump on the barrier and then i
feel ian that pulls on my
on my overall and then
that is an extraordinary feeling
[Music]
staff had a care home which lost a third
of its residents to coronavirus
have told sky news that they feel tired
scared and helpless
bridget could only watch in horror as
the virus spread
across the country a lifetime in care
work
but nothing could prepare her for the
devastation
that was to come we knew there was a
virus out there
um everyone was ten on tender hooks
because we thought if it got in the home
it would spread like wildfire which it
did
didn't matter what you done or
how you tried to avoid it i mean we were
all
going by government guidelines wearing
ppe
and it was keeping people isolated
but obviously it got in
it was just bedlam
um obviously people weren't coming in so
you sat
holding someone's hand um
and you go home in the evening and you
come back the next morning you've lost
three
well we became like their family i mean
um some of us spent more to oh
sorry okay take your time
okay yeah
some of us spent more time at work than
we did at home
and we looked after those people as if
they
were our own one of our and it was
like losing one of your own i held their
round
i held their hand i'm not letting anyone
lie careful die by themselves
you're scarred and scared
because there's another one coming we're
better prepared
but it's my job my job is caring for
people
and that's what i do
[Music]
it was the oldest joke in school careers
lessons
i'd like to be an astronaut but a couple
of english pupils have made it
one of them tim peake has published his
autobiography to inspire anyone
you know when i was growing up i looked
up to the stars and i was kind of always
in wonder about the big questions of the
universe but
aviation was my passion flying was what
i wanted to do
and becoming an astronaut was something
that only became a reality
much later on in my life so it's been a
really interesting journey to get to
that point
and i think when i was growing up it
seemed to be you know astronauts seemed
to be something the russians and the
americans were doing and
there didn't seem to be a route for us
in the uk to become an astronaut so
hopefully things have changed for the
future now at what point then in your
career did it start to become a
possibility the hint of something that
might happen
really it happened when i was working as
a test pilot and i'd gone to
boscom down the the uk's test pilot
school
and i was working much more closely with
the space industry and much more closely
with commercial aviation companies so i
was getting to understand space a bit
more
and then i saw the european space agency
in 2008
they had an application for astronauts
and it just went on the internet and
anybody could apply um you had to go and
get a very basic
aircrew medical and then you could apply
to become an astronaut so that was
really when
you know my journey to becoming an
astronaut started as exciting as it
sounds
you can really begin to appreciate what
nerves of steel
you have to have to go into space is
incredibly dangerous
it's dangerous to be there it's
dangerous to get there
did you ever think you had that sort of
bottle we don't think of ourselves
working in a dangerous environment
but of course you know in the year
before i flew to space i watched
three spacecraft blow up a cygnus a
spacex and a progress vehicle that
you know re-entered earth's atmosphere
and destroyed itself so
you know there were three big reminders
before i launched that things can go
wrong but
i'm passionate about what we do you know
we're pushing the boundaries we're
pushing the limits and i think that we
do need
you know industries and people who are
constantly doing that striving to make
progress
can i ask you about that first launch i
mean obviously you were trained to
within
an inch of your life and the simulators
and all the stuff that you go through
must be
quite remarkable but when you are
strapped in that seat
what on earth is that like that that's
just a moment of pure
excitement and adrenaline and
anticipation of what's coming
i mean your nerves have gone at this
point you know you what will be will be
and so you're just excited about the
launch that's coming up and the sheer
power
and acceleration i mean that's 9 million
horsepower on that sawyer's rocket so
it's phenomenal
when you break sort of out of the
atmosphere and you see the blackness of
space for the first time you see the
the sun and its true white color rather
the yellow we're used to
down here on the planet and the clarity
of the stars all these sort of things i
get excited about
does it change your perspective as a
human being
it completely changes your perspective
and i'm really glad you said there about
the white sun because not many people
pick up about that
but you're right i mean the sun is not
yellow in space
it's it's a nuclear fusion reaction out
there it's the whitest white you could
possibly imagine and it's exceptionally
bright
and we when you see it from space you
know the colors
inside the spacecraft are amazing and
the the earth just looks
absolutely beautiful this wonderfully
beautiful planet against the black
backdrop of the universe and it
completely changes your perspective
i mean it's impossible for any astronaut
to come back you know and not have a
different appreciation
for the planet that we live on and you
know how we need to look after it and
need to work together to make sure that
we do look after it
[Music]
after three years at the helm the
biggest challenge facing the british
editor of vogue isn't who to put on the
front cover
but how to reflect a pandemic and a
global movement
we went from you know pelvic to talking
about environmental issues
to the biggest moment in civil rights
history i mean these incredible
people who were sort of
given their time and their lives to make
sure
that there was social justice in the
world to make sure that there was
education and community care
these were the people who were the new
heroes
more education black awareness
i live opposite hyde park so i put my
mask on
and i went and you know it was the most
peaceful
you know people sat on the floor john
boyega spoke and it was so peaceful
people of all colors and all races were
there
you've been quite frank in your
experiences you've tweeted about you
know being at a fashion show and not
being sat
on the front row with your peers i mean
that was quite brave of you
when you walk into a show and all
fashion directors are in the front row
and you're in the second world straight
away that's you
you know profiling me and i think people
people think that when you're successful
that things like that don't happen
for me the beauty of that incident is it
just makes me aware
never to think i'm too successful
to somebody you're another black person
you did work with the duchess of sussex
and that issue the special issue that
you did with her
um she came in for a lot of criticism
for that
would you put that down to racism sussex
is very she's a brave woman
she's a brave woman i feel that
it wasn't the part of probably raising
but it was more institutional you know
she walked into an institution
and everybody expected her to know the
rules and i think sometimes it takes a
minute to
sort of understand the rules but she did
get a very
unfair treatment i thought for me it's
been so important just
not being the only one but always
bringing people up with me it's not
enough
just having you know sort of black
people on your instagram feed or in a
magazine we've you know we've
accomplished that
but now you know behind the scenes
that's where change really happened
do you feel positive now that that
things
might change i feel that people are
aware now
you know maybe perhaps you know it
wasn't in people's faces but now you
know everybody knows
racism is not just an american problem
you know it's also a british problem
it's a global problem
this claim she was the original
influencer she certainly heiress to one
of the world's most famous hotel
chains paris hilton is an accomplished
businesswoman
model and dj paris hilton has decided
it's time
she tells her story i feel that there's
just been so many misconceptions about
me
so i wanted to show people who i really
was you know back then
they made me like i was the villain
and i'm so grateful that times have
changed
and now women are getting the respect
that they deserve
anyone with a phone could build a
business
or a brand just by showing their talents
or what's
what they love to do their passion and i
think that's an amazing thing with
technology
but see the bad side is just
i can't imagine being a teenage girl and
having to deal with the pressures of
society and perfection
and caring about followers and likes and
you know people coming on your page
writing mean comments
it's just i can't even imagine
how hard that is and just
i don't think it's good for a young girl
to
have to go through that i had been
had been through such traumatic
experiences in life
i feel that all i wanted to do was focus
on my business and my success
and it was probably in a way which i
didn't even realize till
watching my film i think i was doing it
as a distraction to not think about
what i had went through
and that was my goal because all i cared
about was business
but now i'm putting my personal life
first so
of course i'm going to continue working
but
money doesn't buy happiness and that's
not my goal anymore
[Music]
now she is the best best-selling
classical artist
of the century in a voice known across
the world
now catherine jenkins is preparing to
spread some christmas cheer for charity
[Applause]
i was just about to join in do you fancy
a duet single sometime
absolutely we could definitely do
karaoke
[Laughter]
yeah karaoke is probably my limit to be
fair it is really good to see you this
morning talk is about this
this show that you're spreading to
hospitals
uh well i created a film um that we made
at the royal albert hall which is called
the catherine jenkins christmas
spectacular and the sort of the message
of that was
really trying to bring some christmas
cheer to families out there
at the end of a tough year so we made a
few a feature film
full of all of the music from
traditional to contemporary christmas
songs and dance and special guests
um and we've been working with an
amazing charity called
medicine who um show the
show films in hospitals to patients
outpatients
um and to nhs uh staff and so
it's lovely to think that they'll get to
see the film and hopefully it will bring
them a little bit of respite and comfort
and christmas cheer
christmas music is amazing in that you
know it brings us it brings us
joy peace a sense of nostalgia wonderful
memories
and it warms the heart catherine gone
then do us a favor
[Music]
just like the ones i used to know
you've got a great voice you actually
have a great voice
yeah okay let's talk we'll definitely
have to do something that was okay
whatever happens in my life i've done
the duet with captain jacobs
[Music]
across the commonwealth and around the
world we have seen
heartwarming stories of people coming
together to help others
i'm relaxed perfect good exercise well
done everybody
will need some light-heartedness all of
a sudden you feel like you're not on
your own
united in a moment of thanks
[Music]
the organizer of clap for our carers
were you surprised and of course
delighted about how it's all snowball
yes i have certainly been surprised how
every
person or broadcaster everybody
made it their own with respecting of the
thursday night
all got together and showing the
appreciation i would have never dreamed
it would have gone this far that sense
of togetherness
you hear in your neighbors as you say
you see them you hear them from
other roads and then you know that
you're not alone and just to remind us
once again anne-marie
how you came up with the idea it was
taking taking place
already wasn't it in other parts of the
eu
definitely and because i'm originally
dutch i saw it already happening in the
netherlands
and then i heard about how much it
lifted people up like myself being in
houses but especially
how much it lifted the people up working
in the hospitals
so i thought that's such a nice and
simple gesture
let's see if we can do that here as well
and this nation have been amazing with
it
always good to the realization that we
should be appreciated
the people that are out there so that we
can stay indoors and when this is all
over to still be appreciative of them
because they are the backbone of our
society without them we are nowhere
these fundraising efforts saw more than
32 million pounds donated to nhs
charities tom says he'll continue making
laps of the garden
just as long as people keep sponsoring
him sir tom
has really captured the imagination of
so many of us
in this country who's become an icon
is it quite overwhelming that public
support
it is enormous i mean
nobody could have imagined that when we
started
hoping to raise about a thousand pounds
it would ever get to
how it turned out i could never ever
imagine that we
employed when we started we thought oh
maybe a thousand pounds
and the fact that you're now one of the
most famous people at the moment in the
world
and rather than well known at the moment
it's amazing that all these countries
are showing an
interest in what we started off and a
little bit
of a get some money for the
national health service i mean the
doctors and nurses
are putting themselves in mortal danger
day after day
and they seem to be doing it very
cheerfully and
continue and we're doing this
good job and if there's one kind of
message you want to get across to the
public
what would it be i will say to people
please do do remember that things will
get better
as the song says the sun will shine and
we'll
never walk alone not just truly
i believe that to be true but things
will get better
we're live here in coventry where in
this very room
the uk covert 19 vaccine rollout began
in what is being called
v-day with the vaccination of the first
patient in england
outside of trials
[Music]
what went through your mind how did you
feel when the hospital told you
you were going to receive the first
coronavirus vaccination
i thought it was a joke to tell you the
truth to start with
i couldn't believe it you know but i'm
happy it's happened
and now i've done it and hopefully it'll
help
other people come along and
do as i did you know try and
try and do the best for to get rid of
this terrible thing
and as you've been watching the pandemic
and you've seen the effects i did and i
did how did that make you feel
oh terrible what it's done to people you
know
it's such so sudden and so
it's devastating to see what they're
going through really you know
well congratulations for making history
thank you very much indeed
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
we will be with our friends again we
will be with our families again
we will meet again